speak by the way actually speaking of
the republican civil war
um george w bush
has maxed out his donations to two
anti-trump republicans who supported the
impeachment of donald trump i'm talking
about liz cheney yes the daughter of
bush's former vp
and alaska republican senator lisa
murkowski now let me give you the facts
first
but don't assume
what i think is important about the
story because it's not george w bush is
a good guy business insider reporting
george w bush maxes out political
donations to trump impeachment
supporters liz cheney and lisa murkowski
okay
former president george w bush gave the
maximum allowed political contributions
to wyoming representative liz cheney and
alaska senator lisa murkowski two
republicans who supported impeaching
trump over the january sixth capital
riot new disclosures filed with the fec
said bush gave cheney 5 800 on october
28th and on december 31st he gave
murkowski 2900 for her primary the fec
sets the limits on political
contributions
um
the story here is not and this is a key
thing the story here is not
bush is a great guy
we should elect people like bush
we should elect people like liz cheney
and lisa murkowski
we should rehabilitate george w bush's
image now that he's painting and doesn't
like trump
no
that is not the story and it's a very
unfortunate thing and i don't know to
what degree they're cynically doing it
and to what degree they're honestly
doing it there are some on the left who
love to take stories like this one that
i'm doing and say look at these
faux leftists who now love bush despite
him being a disastrous war criminal and
getting us into these two wars
no
the story here is not what a great guy
george w bush is the story here is
the republican civil war
is maybe the best chance the left has to
help itself because the left is
increasingly unable to help itself in
any other way
that's all this is
i am not optimistic
about the left in the united states by
which i mean
the most left elements of the democratic
party which at this point is the one
even possible vehicle for the left to do
anything in the us
i don't have any confidence that in 2022
and 2024 democrats slash leftists
are
well positioned and prepared to get
anything done and so i'm hoping
republicans will help us that's all this
is and the more republicans are divided
the more potential there is for an
opportunity
to defeat them and to prevent them from
taking the house
the senate the white house over the next
two election cycles
let's not forget
that every single republican elected
official
that supported impeachment
is now participating in the obstruction
of letting joe biden do anything these
are not good people and
even if they don't like trump their
obstruction of biden may well help
donald trump get re-elected in three
years so
it's okay to recognize trump was more
incompetent than george w bush and still
not like george w bush and recognize
that bush donating to these republicans
might foment the republican civil war to
our advantage we can do all of these
things we can walk and chew gum at the
same time at least some of us can there
is this impulse
by some
maybe to sweep george w bush's
disastrous misdeeds under the rug
because he's painting pictures and
sharing a cough drop with michelle obama
and
donating to anti-trump republicans
but
he was not a good president
his increase of the powers of the
presidency
are probably to some degree responsible
for uh allowing some of donald trump's
worst abuses when he was president uh
bush got us into
some of the longest wars in american
history one based on a phony
intelligence case that he sent colin
powell to make
um he expanded torture
we're not praising bush and um that's uh
that that's the end of it and and this
is how most people would behave you know
when you attack someone's family or them
the way donald trump did to george w
bush for years
it's normal that george w bush would say
i'm going to donate to the people that
are against this guy it's just totally
reasonable ted cruz did the opposite
donald trump called ted cruz's wife ugly
and then ted cruz fell in line and said
trump's amazing he's fantastic he's
great we love him we love trump
most people wouldn't do that most people
would do what george w bush is doing it
doesn't make him a hero and it doesn't
make him someone we align with
politically period full stop end of
story
let's follow
this republican civil war and see to
what degree it can be useful to the left
to try to get some wins or at least
prevent some losses in the next two
election cycles